we got to apologize to passengers
waiting on platform tree for the slow
running of your high speed rail service
your train is currently running up to
five years late and 67 billion pounds
over budget your patience is appreciated
unlike what you've seen the numbers you
heard didn't just come out of the air
they're accurate horrendously accurate
that's the time delay and cost overrun
for the hs2 project that was given the
full steam go ahead this week by the
government get ready for your taxes to
pay for this project that started at 32
odd billion eight years ago then left
256 billion which was swiftly followed
by 83 billion pounds and now stands at
around 100 billion to reflect this but
here's the thing for the first time in a
long long while I'm effectively at
platforms sixes and sevens over this
while I get the appalling financial
mismanagement and apparent lack of
public approval across much of the
country I also see the prestige and
value in having the biggest
infrastructure project in the whole of
Europe so to my fellow passengers on the
pledge which line should I take now Nick
I have to say that nobody is more
surprised about this than me because I
actually agree with you I don't know
which way to done exactly proach listen
we all know anyone who's taken a train
outside of london particularly in the
north we all know that it's in a woeful
state expensive overcrowded
underserviced
and actually unpleasant oh I'm
pleasantly it's a really not pleasant
experience so we all know that there is
a problem there to address we also know
that the funding lack has been really
acute it's it's 739 pounds per head in
London compared to 305 in the north and
that's been going for on for 10 years so
the impact of that is severe I'm just
not convinced that hs2 is the solution
to that problem
and one of the things that comes up for
me when I look at it is first of all the
east-west problem that needs to be
addressed obviously has to happen
additionally but also if you're if
you're planning this project to solve
this acute problem that we just
described about transport in the north
why would you start in London
why wouldn't you start I would
completely drive vehicle right yeah I'm
kind of where you are on this tool no I
am this in the sense that you know I
don't really understand why Boris is
done at what because we know that this
is not going to be finished till 2040
okay so we know now it's got the
protections now one hundred and six
billion imagine what they're going to be
in 20 years time if he's doing it to
kind of get supported that binner beyond
the red wall in the north they're gonna
hate the waste and the northern people
are the first ones who are gonna kick up
against waste against profligacy against
no disorganization they're gonna kick up
about that and you know no government
ever won an election by improving
transport links however and read the
North so think I think it could increase
the north-south divide in the sense that
more people will just move out of London
and use HS there is a commuting routes
I'm gonna add some color to this debate
right okay I'm sick and tired of our
navel-gazing procrastination and we
can't in this country seem to make a
decision on any infrastructure project
let me give you some examples right he
throw extra runway thing that if that
was meant to have been decided where is
it never gonna be done the Prime
Minister wants to lay himself in front
of the bulldozers to stop it this whole
idea okay so look I mean look how long
it took us to do it
we've got this booming hs2 thing going
on for years I remember when I was stood
as a parliamentary candidate in 2015 I
opposed it because it was in candidate
is gonna cause lots of disruption it's
the never ending story
it's going on and on and on so very plus
I think that we've just got to now
whether it's bricks it whether it's hs2
whether it's the runway extension or
building a bridge which from zooming in
Scotland island just get something
darling come on okay I'm very much with
Rachel on this no I do think that in
general the principle is good improving
improving transport links in general
across the country however haast should
have been top-down yeah I mean if you
we've already seen 490 more spent on
Londoners per head than in the north of
England it when it comes to transport we
have a deeply unfair country if they'd
started in the north that would have
sent a perfect message that this is
about fixing that problem instead this
according to the current plans we won't
get the first leg done until between
2020 nineteen twenty twenty nine and
twenty thirty three which means that
twenty twenty twenty thirty three it's
likely that we will only have maybe an
extra 40 minutes shaved off all the time
between Birmingham and London how is
that helping red car Sunderland etc let
me know shoo Rachel do you think it's a
bit of I was struck by how many
commentators said this is what example
the Boris Johnson do you think it's a
gamble for and politically I think Boris
Johnson likes shiny new projects right
most of which have failed so far I'm
interested in let's have a listen
actually to some stoppages to
campaigners because actually they
address a bit of this question that
you're asking the benefit for this
community is nothing but destruction the
benefit for all the communities in
between Birmingham and London is nothing
but services train services on a local
level on a smaller scale is what the
21st century needs you know when a
climate emergency and this type of
project is a 20th century style of idea
so I think the last the last person to
comment says something really
interesting that's worth picking up on
which is this idea that we do need to
build infrastructure and transport but
we also need to be aware of the climate
crisis and we also need to create jobs
and these things can work in tandem so
we could end up you know maybe a better
direction would be to focus on things
and they're much more localized and
municipal ways it could be greener as
well because this is not terribly
environmentally friendly the top speed
train
we'll use twice as much energy as the
current trains are using they've also
said that there were lower carbon
alternatives and they've turned their
back on them I think what Boris did this
week was really important to five
billion baht scheme that was exactly
what's required and you know we've been
through a long period of austerity and
that's what we should be spending money
on in proper communities and especially
in the North somebody mentioned the
east-west connection so we should hear
from the spokesperson for Midlands
connect James both off it's not worth
building the first leg of HS - if we
don't have the rest of the network going
in both directions up to Manchester and
then through the East Midlands and to
Leeds about two-thirds of the benefits
of high-speed to come in that second leg
that's Bay's to be up from Birmingham
through to the East Midlands and on to
Leeds in the north of England we can't
have one part of HS - without the other
and also these sections to these
Midlands cannot be downgraded you must
have the same benefits that HST brings
to the West Midlands to these Midlands
as well otherwise it just becomes a
London central I think it's fair to say
some of us have reservations let's hear
from someone who's absolutely up for it
Boris Johnson we are today taking
decisive action to restore discipline to
the program I will be a pointier
Minister whose full-time job will be to
oversee the project a new ministerial
oversight group will be tasked with
taking strategic decisions about it
there will be changes to the way hs2 is
managed we will in line with mr. to
these recommendations be interrogating
the current costs to identify where
savings could be made in phase one
without the costs and delays that would
be associated with a detailed redesign
imagine that pledges the phone rings
your partner your husband your wife it's
the Prime Minister you're going to be
the HS - Minister oh cool you don't want
poison chalice